durante mucho tiempo el proceso fue así
se cosecha se fabrica se vende o no se
tira o se quema sólo unas pocas personas
marginales atípicas o rezagadas pensaron
que era urgente romper este molde y
entonces se impuso la idea la moda
contamina el medio ambiente hay que
actuar porque lo que es bueno para el
planeta será también bueno para el
negocio hoy en día el desarrollo
sostenible se ha convertido en una
realidad el instituto francés de la moda
presenta el trabajo de una primera
promoción de estudiantes que han seguido
un curso totalmente nuevo el certificado
de desarrollo sostenible aquí formamos a
unos 1000 estudiantes en la industria de
la moda tienen entre 18 y 24 años y para
ellos es algo totalmente natural han
nacido con ellos son totalmente
conscientes de ello obviamente en
términos de pedagogía esto lo cambia
todo el año pasado creamos una cátedra
la cátedra y fm que nos ha permitido
contratar a un profesor y haber elevado
y ampliado considerablemente todo
nuestro nivel de enseñanza sobre
responsabilidad social y medioambiental
y luego tratamos
desarrollar programas que no sean solo
de concientización sino de acción acción
es decir empujar a los estudiantes a
hacer y realizar en su trabajo diario
prototipos aplicaciones creaciones que
sean compatibles con el desarrollo
sostenible si estamos en el movimiento
eso es seguro y se va a acelerar estamos
convencidos de que formará la próxima
generación en un enorme potencial de
acción y eso es lo que queremos hacer
con la nueva generación de la moda
podemos identificar algunas tendencias
importantes
tanto para los grupos de lujo como para
todas las marcas esto se ha convertido
en una obligación y está fuera de lugar
no escuchar los deseos de los clientes
los consumidores sobre todo los que se
denominan actualmente millennials y geni
z ya van un paso adelante cuestionan las
marcas controvierten las marcas y
también esperan que las marcas sean
capaces de darles productos que sean a
la vez muy bonitos que tengan calidad
pero que realmente hayan integrado
parte del planeta en su modo de
producción así que los consumidores nos
empujan y eso es algo muy bueno los
estudiantes del instituto francés de la
moda compartieron así la vida cotidiana
de los especialistas en supra reciclaje
durante unos meses en anthony un
suburbio de parís
la asociación renacimiento les ha
abierto sus puertas este es un tema muy
importante en este momento y estas
personas siguen precisamente esta
capacitación sobre el desarrollo
sostenible es un nuevo negocio nos
dedicamos al súper reciclaje de lujo
este vestido de hecho es resultado de un
par de pantalones de jean paul gautier
que fueron de construidos para ser
reconstruidos y hacer un vestido cuál es
el objetivo principal de la asociación
que personas con grandes dificultades
consigan un empleo
philip que les enseña los conocimientos
de las casas de alta costura para
reciclar por ejemplo la ropa profesional
estos modelos se han realizado a partir
de la ropa reglamentaria que llevan los
empleados de los aeropuertos de parís es
necesario tener un conocimiento sólido
en dirección de arte que es usted es
quien diseña estos modelos de hecho aquí
no estamos haciendo
lo que hacemos es simplemente poner mi
toque en la ropa real es decir intentó
aplicar los métodos y las diferentes
técnicas que practicamos en los talleres
para que mis alumnos aprendan al máximo
de cosas y sap conamaq simón de sus en
cuanto a los cuatro estudiantes del
instituto francés de la moda cuál es su
papel desarrollar nuevos planes de
negocio
está el tema de la industrialización del
súper reciclaje que no es fácil de no
nuestro reto era encontrar una forma de
industrializar las empresas o salvar
estas prendas a su vez el fabricadas de
forma súper recicladas cycling también
en los suburbios del sur de parís la
asociación es pero que ayuda a los
exiliados para su proyecto en el
instituto francés de la moda luz y link
él creó un método para que diseñaran
ponchos a partir de viejos suéteres de
lana reciclados las prendas de punto son
estupendas en muchos sentidos
podemos hacer nuestro propio textil
porque podemos elegir los vídeos de
tablets más responsables y esto es una
ventaja que es realmente grande en
comparación con la cadena y la trama
las prendas de punto están actualmente
en auge por eso quise aprender esta
especialidad centre a marco bar cree que
todo se puede reciclar la prueba está en
estas prendas hechas con cámaras de
neumáticos de bicicleta y origami de
latas de refresco y cuando trabaja con
hilo es cien gora pelo de perro
hace tiempo que dejé de usar telas
compradas en tiendas y me pregunte cómo
podría ser mi propia vibra con fibras
que se pueden encontrar en la ciudad y
aquí en parís pregunté qué animales
viven aquí en países y me dije no hay
ovejas viviendo cerca de mí son más bien
perros y gatos así que empecé a buscar
peluqueros uno por uno yendo puerta a
puerta a ver que podía conseguir que así
es como es
alucinante o no marko trabaja en dúo con
estudiantes de la escuela de estudios
superiores de comercio hs para
industrializar su concepto realmente
creemos que hemos encontrado una
alternativa sostenible a las fibras
tradicionales porque como te
el costo del transporte no tenemos que
ir a mongolia agua china para encontrar
cachemira estamos pensando en crear una
marca que sea verdaderamente el lujo
como puede ver una nueva sociedad está
tomando forma lo que plantea muchas
preguntas en el desarrollo sostenible
cómo medir exactamente el contenido del
carbón como medio de impacto sobre los
recursos el agua cómo combinar estos
criterios en un eventual lo que son
temas muy importantes está poniendo es
que hay que trabajar continuamente
buscando de un enfoque sí me gustaría
destruir técnico económico ya que todo
esto gira en torno a la moda y a la
creación respuestas que esperamos sean
proporcionadas en las próximas décadas
por los estudiantes del instituto
francés de la moda con su certificado de
desarrollo sostenible debajo del brazo